with every passing day it becomes easier
and easier to impersonate someone else's
likeness now there's times when this is
used for art and entertainment and it's
great but there's times when this is
also cross the line in fact we recently
paid a visit by William Osmond and he
told us a story where he had to deal
with this exact thing so that really
inspired me to make this video because I
want to arm people with the knowledge on
how to spot fake synthesized people so I
called up one of my friends who happens
to be in my opinion one of the best deep
fake artists on the planet Chris ume and
Chris will explain to us how do you spot
a deep fake how do you break a deep fake
and can you even make a perfect
undetectable deep fake and by the end of
this video we're going to try to answer
perhaps the most important question
under all of this
when is it okay to fake somebody
let's go find out
let's start with the story hi Will hello
so you got some buddies and there's
people who are impersonating your
buddies I would say caricature
impersonation there's a channel called
now red who does chemistry Safety First
well no it's just stupidity last he is a
friend of mine for the past three years
he's got a second Channel now blue but
the audience does is they go and they
make Nile other colors there's Nile pink
now brown and they're all kind of
Nile Brown specifically yeah okay but
this young man made an account called
now green no longer actually called Nile
green anymore I think Mr greeny changed
his name too the dude started creating
some of the best parody deep bait
content I have ever seen step one find
yourself a small container to hold the
chemicals step two this wasn't big
enough so I found a bigger container I
gotta say this defects pretty good it's
it's it was a very like confusing
experience because it's so good yeah
that's the problem yeah it's like oh
this is actually kind of good we've had
long conversations trying to figure out
like like how good is too good like like
you've never had this issue before on
the internet like it's always been like
bad enough that you could immediately
tell it was like total BS I think part
of the issue is that the entire channel
was packaged to look like one of Nigel's
channels so it's starting to depart from
like we're making a joke or a parody yes
satire too like we're trying to like I'm
becoming this person it's one thing to
to piggyback off of nails but then he
goes
they steal all my packages problem is I
don't know how to make better high class
explosives so last week I tweeted my
home address it's the classic problem
with deep fakes that I see immediately
is just face and body shape don't match
you don't realize you know the body
shape and face shape of someone until
you see someone else's face shape but
with their face and you're like ah it's
wrong looks like Mark Rover's meth head
brother
like obviously like you can tell it's
not Mark Rover but watching this on your
phone or like a kid yeah like a
six-year-old kid 360 p and I'm like a
cheap phone like you're not gonna be
able to tell he makes Marco recall one
of the squirrels a [ __ ] fat Gus was
being not moving so I put that little
where he belonged I think it was really
funny to see Mark Rover say [ __ ] I also
think that if I was Mark Rober I would
probably not be super happy with it like
if someone was making me say bad thing I
mean because you know if you can make
Mark over she can make them say anything
and that's kind of like well if we're
Towing that line you can kind of you
know see the progression of potentially
getting worse and worse and worse the
dude led into a sponsored segment using
Mark Rober it's one thing if it was just
some brand integration but it was a very
specific one that is kind of what made
me feel kind of weird about it because
it was a subscription box that is a
direct competitor to the subscription
box that Mark has he knew where to draw
the line like Mark Rober basically is
about to say like this video is
sponsored but then it like cuts off and
then the Creator comes in and does the
sponsor segment
he found that line like he went right to
the edge of it because the videos are
hilarious it's just the income the
entire thing that kind of starts to
become questionable yeah
so while we're talking about defects I
know somebody who is creating
world-class defects in my opinion Chris
ume and Chris and I met when we were
both working for the South Park team
briefly kicking off deep Voodoo which is
their like AI deep fake division but
since then you've got on to create this
company metaphysic you guys have
actually done some pretty impressive
work I started working on this Tick Tock
Channel named deep Tom Cruise where I
created like artificial videos of a
young Tom Cruise doing crazy things like
eating a lollipop and all these kind of
things
I think there's bubble gum inside there
all right let's say I'm an internet
detective and I'm like all right I have
this shot and I I don't know if it's a
deep thick or not so I'm going to turn
to one of the best artists I know who
makes some of the most realistic deep
fix I've ever seen what would you look
for if I handed you this piece of video
what would you look for to tell if it
was a deep fake there are a few specific
things you can look at first there's
like General expression and in fact you
always lose expression and that's just a
feeling it is also very important to
look at the shape of the face I think
the shape of the face is always a
giveaway because if it's a celebrity
you're most likely using a look-alike in
a lot of cases their measurements are
not perfect so you can look at the
length of the forehead the size of the
chin even the distance between the eyes
the best thing is to just hold a picture
next to it or a few pictures and start
comparing right and also are the eyes
perfectly aligned there is still an
issue with a lot of fakes where the
right eyes for example looking there and
left eye is like in between somewhere
like I'm not sure what it's doing and
it's like only in still frames that you
can detect those so it's something you
can look at a difficult thing as well is
is side angles whenever the phase is
moving side angles are mostly the weak
spots and that's got to do with the type
of facial extractions we have currently
in general in a lot of these tools
there's also the Madame tusso effect
because a lot of these models are not
capable of doing these high high high
quality resolutions yet but the Madame
tussa effect you get this wax stall like
it's all enhanced and like it's looks
real but at the same time it's like
um it's like that in any Valley which
you can feel coming coming closer and
closer it's also difficult to fake ears
here's a really specific for everyone so
not a lot of people with the same ears
and in deep some Crews as well I'm not
using Tom Cruise's here so I'm using
miles of years like the actor and it
just makes it easier
of course the way the model is moving
compared to the voice it's it's not
perfect either besides quality issues is
also the general blending as in is the
face matching is the skin color perfect
but if you're working with experienced
compositors that shouldn't be an issue I
thought you just hit a button and it
just happened like what's the actual
ratio of like an AI did the work versus
like people sat down with a mouse and
keyboard and did the work I think
currently it's 50 50 is fair is a fair
way to say it like it's a lot of
artistry and that's where the human
touch comes in no I love voice
so Chris while we're on the subject of
the challenging parts of replicating
somebody's likeness can you tell me what
what did you do for America's Got Talent
we made Elvis Presley come back
thank you
thank you very much damn that that looks
like Elvis I can really see the
experience in how you set up this deep
fake here because all the things that
can break it you've really controlled
the environment not to have those things
be an issue it's working really well it
was also an honor that the the estate
gave us the possibility and trusted us
to do this interesting he didn't just
you didn't just go who should we do
let's do Elvis and you just grab
pictures of him you actually had to
contact the estate and work through that
process yeah I think we had to have
something like seven approvals wow it's
interesting like the thought of going
through all that effort to speak to his
mistakes you know like Elvis is a public
figure you can parody public figures you
can represent them like you can do fan
films you can do jokes like in this
situation you know you went through the
route of actually working with his
estate and talking to them and getting
their approval one one factor is the
commercial side of it right it's going
to go on a show or it's going to be run
against advertisements and so you start
getting into exploiting of someone's
image versus just satire you weren't
satirizing you know you weren't making
fun of Elvis or having a joke about
you're actually trying to replicate an
authentic performance like really
capturing his Vibe and so if there
weren't any legalities that you had to
worry about or anything like that let's
say you were immune to being sued would
you still have gone through that process
of talking to his estate yeah I think
it's very important that with all of
these things it's very important that
you have consent for what you're doing
you cannot just bring someone back
because you want to do that right it's
not because he can do it that you should
do it that's the only way how I feel
about it once your guns at me instead
there's no way we can communicate
effectively when you have guns pointed
at each other's heads I wonder how Keanu
Reeves feels about our video of him
stopping a robbery by flipping a dude's
neck a couple times like it's it's in
that category where it's like oh it's
obviously fake because it's all parody
it's all part of the story of that video
but it is still Keanu Reeves likeness do
doing this stuff without his consent
Keanu right at least it was just an
impersonator's voice and not a full-on
AI Keanu Reeves voice there's something
about impersonation though where it's
like it's always imperfect right and a
lot of times it's almost funnier when
it's imperfect I agree like SNL not
saying SNL is funny but
the like the caricature impersonation
yeah or like there's like a lot of
comedy and just sort of a really like
kind of weird version of the person
they're they're yeah you know you want
one human's interpretation of the
eccentricities of another yes taking it
and making it like almost as perfect as
it can get using you know like
essentially mathematics is that to me is
the part that is a little bit too clean
okay yeah you're simulating the human
being yeah exactly like a lot of the the
viewers like the audience I think didn't
quite understand why it would bother us
and and and Nigel and that took me by
surprise because I think most people
would probably be uncomfortable with
someone else publishing you know fake
videos and photos of them and that
bothered me a lot because like I get it
I get it like I understand why like I
like the videos
if somebody made a parody of me and they
made one video I would be okay with that
if I started seeing like a pattern where
it kind of felt like somebody was sort
of jumping onto my back it would make me
very uncomfortable I noticed that he
only had five videos on his channel he
doesn't have any defects on his channel
anymore correct he just has deep voice
the defects are gone yeah I gotta give
this guy props for navigating this
because clearly he is putting effort
into navigating it he's trying to figure
out where he sits he's trying not to
actually upset people
you know it makes me actually a little
proud that there's a good sense of
community and culture here that's cool
so Props to you Mr Green I think I think
that he can make it work he like has to
kind of get the approval of the people
that he's doing it of with Hyper real
synthetic media and we're bridging that
uncanny valley it's really difficult to
see the difference between what's real
and what's what's not real the sadar is
a really difficult thing it's a gray
area like how far can you go you cannot
just make people say weird stuff and
then make people believe it's them right
if you want to utilize someone's image
and you don't have the permission like
you can't make it believable you need to
make sure it's like really a satire a
representation a caricature you know at
the end of the day it's like it's up to
us as individuals and as artists and as
an audience to really find what we feel
is okay because it's the culture that
you set that really establishes the
rules that people follow it would suck
we didn't set up the right community and
culture around this tool because it
could be used for so many interesting
positive things if it's used for the
wrong cases and it gets that kind of
reputation and that's why people are
using it then it can just kind of
torpedo this entirely new like growing
art form yeah I'm excited to see what
happens I'm just glad I didn't have to
be the the face that started the
conversation
so there you have it a really
interesting conversation with two really
interesting people but it doesn't just
end with them I want to hear what you
guys think the synthetic media it's this
crazy new thing it's here to stay and
one of the really cool things that you
see none of this what would you like to
see done with it in the future as always
consider subscribing really appreciate
all of you watching this video and
engaging in the discussion with us we're
gonna keep trying new things as we move
forward here